donald trump en miami yo vaivén en
filadelfia
tras la cancelación del segundo debate
de los candidatos a la presidencia de
eeuu
los aspirantes realizaron eventos por
separado de re cuestionar y con el
presidente en la cadena en bici news
aseguró que durante años ha denunciado
el supremacismo blanco y puede masivo
sobre las pruebas de hojs 19 que le han
tomado se hizo una prueba el día del
debate y creo que probablemente lo hice
me hicieron una prueba el día antes y el
día antes y siempre estuvo bien
después del debate como un tiempo
después del debate es interesante me
hicieron una prueba y dispositivos para
aclarar se hace pruebas todos los días
no pero me he hecho muchos entonces no
sabe si se hizo una prueba el día del
debate
posiblemente me la hice posiblemente no
hago por su parte yo vaivén en la cadena
ibis y volvió a cargar contra el jefe de
estado y contra su administración por el
manejo de la pandemia el punto es que el
presidente perdió oportunidades enormes
y continuó diciendo cosas que no eran
verdad recuerden que el presidente les
dijo
gobernadores están por su cuenta no es
mi responsabilidad los gobernadores
pueden hacer lo que quieran no es mi
responsabilidad es responsabilidad del
presidente liderar y él no lo disfruta
aún falta definir si se realizará el
debate programado para el 22 de octubre
en la ciudad de nashville ese sería el
último cara cara de los aspirantes antes
de las elecciones del 3 de noviembre